le département et antenn Réunion vous
présente lien
[Musique]
social à la Réunion on recense 15000
personnes en état de dépendance
lorsqu'elles sont adultes il faut
anticiper des solutions d'accompagnement
pour soutenir et rassurer les parents
vieillissants l'irsam est un partenaire
historique du conseil départemental
l'établissement prend en charge des
adultes déficien intellectuelle Olga et
Michell sont deux résidents des foyers
d'accueil du Moufia un nouveau site
inauguré en
[Musique]
2015 il est 10h du matin au Moufia à
lirsam l'atelier musique peut
commencer au programme une revisite des
grands classiques du F
[Musique]
réunionn l'irsam l'Institut Régional des
Sour et aveugle de Marseille est une
association dont 45 % de l'activité
s'exerce à la Réunion c'est 25
établissements et service répartis sur
la région PACA Lyon et la Réunion c'est
une association qui accueille des
adultes déficients alors ça peut être
des déficien sensorielles pour la
majorité de l'établissement enfin de
association et des déficients
intellectuels pour notre établissement
nous avons deux sortes de d'accueil un
accueil en foyer médicalisé pour 15
résidents et un accueil en foyer
occupationnel pour 60 résidents à 64 ans
olga est la doyenne du FEM le foyer
d'accueil médicalisé elle a du mal à se
déplacer seule le rythme plus calme de
ce mode d'accueil est donc mieux adapté
à son âge et son handicap pour autant
Olga continue de participer aux ateliers
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme VI la
cuisine dans la jnée on participe avec
les résidents on parle beaucoup on
discute on fait des activités par
exemple musique ou bien théâtre ou bien
n'importe quoi il par dans la tête il il
fait j'aime bien ici moi je suis comme à
maison c'est donc comme en famille Colga
prend son repas patricia est sa
référente elle veille sur la résidente
pendant son séjour
est accue de jour les soirs et weekend
elle rentre chez sa mère à Châ orangga
vient du lundi au vendredi voil pas le
weekend le weekend pas donc du lundi au
vendredi
et de 9h à 16h c'est important pour eux
aussi de venir ici pour ils savent que
c'est pour maintenir l'autonomie en même
temps aussi les parentsent souffler
aussi le centre ident en internat c'est
le cas de Michell voilà c'est la salle à
manger la salle de télé qui est juste
là-bas le salon à 22 ans le jeune homme
est en foyer d'accueil occupationnel
depuis un an j'habite à salasie en fait
j'habite dans les haau donc je peux pas
rentrer chez moi tous les soirs donc je
passe ici la semaine avec les les autres
résidents l'après-midi Michel retrouve
Volga pour le deuxè atelier de la
journée cette fois les résidents
travaillent sur la réalisation de leur
propre blog encadré par Aline on va
écrire là
présidente avec un P majuscule il y a
plusieurs objectifs déjà bah voilà c'est
une ouverture vers l'extérieur quand
même donc on met en ligne nos nos
moments de vie sur internet après ça
leur permet aussi de maintenir leurs
acquis puisque bon voilà on on rédige on
tape sur l'ordinateur euh et puis ça
fait aussi un travail aussi de mémoire
de d'expression de verbalisation c'est
intéressant parce que c'est nous-même
qui donneent des idées et puis c'est
bien de créer un blog pour pour les
autres pour découvrir peut-être
peut-être serait intéressant pour des
jeunes comme nous qui veulent venir le
sujet du jour la visite de Nassima
Dindar la veille la présidente du
département a visité le centre les
foyers d'accueil étaient auparavant
situés à Saint-François et Sainte-Marie
en 2015 ils ont été rassemblé sur un
site neuf plus grand et mieux adapté les
foyers sont en partie financés par le
Conseil
lirsam est un partenaire incontournable
associatif du département sur
l'accompagnement des politique en faveur
des personnes porteuses de handicap et
nous avons beaucoup de porteurs de
handicap qui vivent en plus aujourd'hui
de plus en plus longtemps et c'est
heureux les parents vieillissants ont
aussi besoin d'être rassurés de savoir
comment seront accompagnés après un
départ et ben c ces adultes nous avons
en en place d'accueil près pr de 2800
places il en manque mais nous avons
aussi des places chez les accueillants
familiaux qui sont aussi susceptible
d'accueillir des adultes handicapés et
qui reçoivent une formation de la part
du Conseil départemental la collectivité
et les équipes soignantes travaillent
donc main dans la main pour garantir aux
personnes porteuses de handicap le
meilleur accompagnement possible tout au
long de leur
[Musique]
vie l'irsam prend en charge les
personnes porteuses de handicap il gère
cinq établissements à la Réunion un
foyer d'accueil occupationnel un foyer
d'accueil médicalisé et un service pour
déficients visuels regroupé au Moufia à
sainteclotildde un foyer d'accueil
médicalisé à la Plaine des Palmistes un
service pour déficients visuels à
Saint-Louis les foyers d'accueil
proposent un accueil de jour un internat
la semaine ou un internat complet les
demandes d'admission se font par
courrier par téléphone ou par
notification de la MDPH pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez vous
rapprocher de la Maison départementale
des personnes handicapées ou consulter
le site de lirsam au
[Musique]
www.irsam.fr